hey guys let me ask you a question and
be honest
are you happy with your body
when you take a shower and you get a
glimpse of yourself in the mirror are
you okay with what you look like if
you're not then why don't you get rid of
it the other day a good friend of mine
he asked me daniel do you think that
i'll ever get rid of this big belly i
looked at him and said of course
he was surprised and i was surprised
because he was surprised because he did
not believe that it was possible and
that is why most men don't lose weight
because it is all in your head and you
won't lose weight if you can't control
your mind so my first step to lose
weight is to control your mind
because if you master your mind you'll
also be able to master your body and to
do it you need to focus on five
important things now this is important
so write this down number one goals
number two dedication number three
discipline number four habits number
five consistency and then just repeat
these numbers over and over
[Music]
start to write down your goals first
ask yourself what do you want to look
like in three months from now in six
months in one year
then dedicate yourself to achieving
those goals every single day how do you
do that you need to discipline yourself
by creating a weekly routine of when you
eat what you eat when you sleep and when
you work out then you change all your
bad habits and replace them with good
ones that will ultimately give you a
healthy lifestyle then all you need to
do is to be consistent that is why most
men fail because they are not consistent
because they fail in all of these five
things most men do not fail because of
their workout routine or because of
their diet plan and there are thousands
of diet plans out there workout routines
and yes some of them are terrible just
quick fixes that really never work but
the real problem is that people cannot
adapt to a healthy lifestyle to stay
consistent that is why even if they lose
some weight over a few months they will
always get it all back so please listen
to me today
be consistent focus on these five things
control your mind to be able to control
your body and then
adapt to a healthy lifestyle that is the
best workout routine the best diet plan
is a healthy lifestyle this has been
true for thousands of years and it's
still true today and i'm also proof of
it these days a lot of companies they
just want to make money right so they
bring out workout routines diet plans
and they bring out new stuff to lose fat
faster but people try it
doesn't work as well as they thought it
would then they try something else then
they try something else and they just
keep on going and they don't fix the
root of the problem which is their mind
so let me help you to adapt to a healthy
lifestyle and to control your mind so to
do this this is how it works i'm going
to give you 10 tips
10 basic healthy lifestyle changes that
you need to make and if you do it you
will lose the weight you will look
better you will be able to actually tie
your shoelaces comfortably and you will
also have more energy are you ready to
do this are you ready to change your
life
respect your body enough to take good
care of yourself and to do it so come on
let's do this
[Music]
number one
stay away from sugar stay away from all
kinds of sugar and i mean all kinds of
sugar a lot of people are addicted to
sugar without even realizing it and did
you know that sugar is actually the
biggest drug in the world killing more
people than cocaine and heroin combined
yeah scary isn't it calories is not
calories anymore if you eat just
calories of sugar and calories of let's
say any kind of lean meat is not going
to have the same effect on your body
sugar contains huge amount of calories
with no essential nutrients not only
does it make you fat but it also
increases the risk of diabetes heart
disease cancer and many other health
problems
you gotta understand that if food
industry changed over the last few years
just like most of companies today just
focused on making money
and then you get a lot of people that
just suddenly they have health problems
because
the food industry started to put sugar
into almost all kind of foods there is
sugar and bread in fruit juice
in instant cereals cereal bars
and fake healthy cookies and the list
just goes on
[Music]
maintain a healthy sleeping routine
it is crucial if you wanna lose weight
try to sleep between seven to eight
hours every day look if you don't sleep
enough your cortisol levels rise and
cortisol is your stress hormone that is
associated with
weight gain man i've talked about the
importance of sleep so many times on my
channel if by now it doesn't sink in
nothing probably will if you don't
understand the importance of sleep
you're going to have a tough life ahead
of you sleep deprivation also causes
your body to produce ghrelin which is a
hormone that increases appetite and fat
storage
[Music]
replace your bad food habits this is
very important look our bodies they were
created to be amazing right they can
take a lot
but you have to stop forcing it to take
in all that bad unhealthy food because
your body can only take so much and then
you will experience bad health problems
so let me quickly help you with this eat
the following food nuts without sugar or
syrup or anything on it just
healthy nuts they're one of the best
snacks that you can eat and they are
loaded with antioxidants that help you
to lose weight and they also help with
lower cholesterol and if you can choose
almonds over other nuts because they are
the healthiest
beans and legumes not normal baked beans
in a can no normal healthy beans they
are packed with protein fiber iron and b
vitamins and they will help you to lose
weight they'll also help you to prevent
heart disease fight cancer and lower
cholesterol but just a word of warning
don't eat too much of them because well
apart from farting
they can also cause you to get migraines
and also high blood pressure
dairy products oh man some people might
disagree with me here and a lot of
people probably will
and that's fine because that's your
choice right but most studies show that
good healthy dairy products help with
weight loss and improve body composition
and it's also a super food for your
bones oatmeal i eat this almost every
day of my life it's one of the best
healthiest grains that you can eat just
choose natural oatmeal or whole cut oats
without any sugar in it look oats for
i love oats they're awesome and they've
got a lot of benefits it helps with
weight loss enhances your immune system
and stabilizes blood sugar it contains
healthy fiber protein and vitamin b
complex and then if you're struggling
with cholesterol
eat oats because it will help you as
well
the next one is eggs they're amazing and
they help you with weight loss but
just don't fry them in unhealthy oil one
big egg contains only 77 calories
and it's a superfood that is full of
healthy protein vitamins and minerals
oh yeah before i forget if you're new to
my channel and you like my videos so far
you might like the other videos on my
channel as well so remember to subscribe
and also click that notification bell
here so you'll be notified whenever i
upload a new video i would really love
the support now let's move on to the
next one
lean protein lean protein is just a must
for a healthy balanced diet it fuels fat
burning strengthens your immune system
and repairs damaged cells so eat lean
protein like beef chicken fish and
turkey in south africa we also have
ostrich which is so awesome because it's
so lean
healthy oils a lot of people think that
they're eating healthy right but then
they prepare their food in an unhealthy
manner they use unhealthy oils so choose
better healthier oils to make your food
in for example 100
olive oil or coconut oil instead of
sunflower or canola oil
olive oil is backed with vitamin e and
antioxidants coconut oil is high in
medium chain triglycerides which are
fatty acids that are metabolized
differently than most other fats and
this of course helps you to lose weight
whole grains please listen to me today
stay away from all kinds of unhealthy
white bread and white pasta they really
are so bad for you because once you eat
them your body kind of treats them like
sugar whole wheat bread and pasta has
more fiber and is more filling compared
to normal bread and pasta and studies
show that people who choose whole wheat
products have lower risk of obesity and
lower cholesterol i also have to be
honest and mention this because it
depends on where you live in which
country because these days some whole
wheat products are also genetically
modified and that's not that healthy for
you either
whey protein i only use whey protein on
the days that i work out on the days
that i don't work out i don't really use
it but whey protein is probably the best
source of good healthy protein that you
can get but never get the extreme muscle
gain whey protein products because in it
you'll find a lot of nonsense and sugar
but good whey protein is the most
thermogenic food source what does that
mean well it burns the most calories
after you consumed it i'll add my best
options of white protein for you in the
video description so you can go and
check it out
[Music]
fruit now you've probably heard this
when you were younger a doctor today
keeps that no no
an apple a day gives the doctor away
right
not really but the idea behind it is
good if you eat healthy it will keep the
doctor away and when it comes to fruit
research shows that fruit can help you
with weight loss especially if you have
a sweet craving
so always choose healthy fruits over
sweets because it contains natural
fructose and fiber which reduces the
risk of cancer diabetes stroke heart
attack and high blood pressure now when
it comes to weight loss specifically the
fruit that will help you the most are
probably
berries and grapefruit
leafy green veggies they're awesome for
example spinach collards and swiss chard
are very low in calories while also
being full of fiber vitamins
antioxidants and minerals
that of course will help you to lose fat
as well all right guys now you know what
food options are better to go for so
let's continue with number four of
changing towards a healthy lifestyle
[Music]
stay away from soft drinks here in south
africa a lot of people are addicted to
coke i mean coca-cola coke it's actually
scary how most of the world are just so
used to drinking coke every single day
soft drinks and it's actually a type of
drug because it's addictive studies show
that just after six minutes it can
deplete nutrients making you hungrier
and also thirsty for more now do you
know how much sugar there is in one can
of coke you get 40 grams of sugar in one
can of coke which is around 8 teaspoons
of sugar
man i'm not going to be that cruel to my
own body forcing my body to take that in
every day no
this is what basically happens to your
body when you drink coke soft drinks
your blood sugar levels increase
dramatically causing a huge spike of
insulin your poor liver then turns the
high amount of sugar circulating in your
body into fat
[Music]
drink enough water
you gotta drink between seven to eight
glasses of water per day that's one and
a half liters to two liters depending on
how big you are how much you need but
water is life and not only is it good
for just flushing toxins out of your
body it's also good for weight loss
studies show that water actually speeds
up weight loss and remember water
contains no calories and it boosts your
metabolism
now just a reminder drinking coffee or
tea or something with water in it is not
100 water just drink normal 100
water
read before you buy
read the food labels the ingredients
list take a look at it because man the
food industry changed over the last few
years and they mislead thousands of
people every single day here are just a
few crazy facts if you see low-fat or
fat-free products it does not mean that
it is healthier than other products
because i take out the fat but then they
add more sugar just for the taste which
is far worse than fat
listen even fruit juice went from health
food to junk food i'm not joking because
the food industry started to add sugar
and water into fruit juices
today you also can't find any bread
without sugar in it everything's got
sugar in these days just it tastes
better and you go and you buy more in
places like china you can't even fight
whole wheat bread anymore
so check the labels check the
ingredients list to see what you're
actually eating
[Applause]
eat your favorite healthy foods
if you start on a whole new lifestyle
change you you learn new habits and you
try to move away from your old bad
habits of eating unhealthy it's easier
said than done right so the trick is you
need to learn how to make delicious food
that's healthy and that you actually
like to eat create food that is
delicious for you and then you won't
struggle to eat healthy and then just
make it into a lasting habit start with
small changes try new recipes and find
ways of thinking about food differently
a lot of people think that when you say
healthy food they think it's bland i'm
appetizing food that's not gonna taste
good
it can't be further from the truth i
mean i eat a lot of good tasting food
that is also healthy you just need to
learn how to prepare food look at food
differently and choose the food that you
personally like
[Music]
drink more green tea and coffee did he
just say coffee yes i said coffee
believe me it's not unhealthy it's
actually a lot more healthier than those
soft drinks that you're drinking
the only thing is don't add sugar into
your coffee
at first it's going to be difficult
because it's going to taste strange
right but do it just force yourself to
do it for a month and see how you like
it you're not going to want to go back
to your sugar in the coffee because then
it's going to taste disgusting that's
how i taught myself how to drink coffee
without any sugar coffee gives your
metabolism a boost which helps you to
lose more weight
coffee also has a huge amount of
antioxidants which increases your
short-term memory while also lowering
the risk of certain cancers and diabetes
coffee can also enhance exercise
performance and it helps with depression
it even protects you against gout now
you probably didn't know some of that
did you a lot of people think man coffee
is unhealthy but then those same people
they are the ones that just drink soft
drinks every day and that's far worse
for you now let's take a look at green
tea green tea is well known for its
weight loss effects right
but it also improves brain function and
lowers the risk of cancer alzheimer's
and parkinson's to be honest i never
liked drinking green tea it didn't taste
that good for me but i learned to drink
it when i was in asia and the good thing
about green tea is that it kills certain
bacteria like the bacteria that causes
bad breath and it lowers the risk of
infection as well
intermittent fasting have you ever tried
intermittent fasting well if you want to
lose weight faster this is something
that you gotta try if you look at all
the diets out there all the quick fixes
and stuff and
all you gotta do is just focus on living
a healthier lifestyle right eat the
healthier food options and then do
intermittent fasting because it lowers
insulin and blood sugar levels while at
the same time also raising your glucagon
levels which of course helps you to lose
more weight faster now this is perfect
for people of faith people who do
fasting for their faith for example i'm
a reborn christian so i do intermittent
fasting sometimes now there are six
options that you can choose from and i
would recommend you do the 16 hours
eight hours fast this is how it works
you fast for 16 hours and the other
eight hours you eat is that simple it
might sound rough to beginners but
honestly it's not that difficult you can
do this all you need to do is just skip
breakfast or you skip your dinner for
example if you skip breakfast you just
eat from lunchtime to 8 p.m and then you
skip breakfast again the next day now
you can also drink water and coffee
black coffee if you do your fast but if
you are a beginner just be careful here
at the start especially if you do longer
fasts you might get headaches heartburn
or you might start binge eating or
drinking too much coffee or not eating
enough
cheat meals eat a cheat meal once a week
look if you if you're changing towards a
healthy lifestyle it's all psychological
so a lot of people do things that they
don't like and then it's harder for them
to stick to that healthy lifestyle for
example i hate counting calories i don't
like it i don't like to go and
specifically count my calories that i
eat every single day so i don't do it i
mean i know roughly how much calories i
take in
but i don't count the calories of every
single little thing that i put into my
body so one thing that will help you to
just stick to a healthy lifestyle is
to work hard to discipline yourself and
then
to treat yourself right reward yourself
to a unhealthy meal anything you want to
do anything ice cream pizza anything
just eat one unhealthy meal at the end
of the week for example i love pizza so
once in a while i will go and have my
pizza and i'll enjoy it and i won't feel
guilty about it now just don't overdo it
remember it's a cheat meal not a cheat
day
so don't go overboard
[Music]
all right we're at the bonus step the
bonus tip are for you guys who are still
watching the video all the way to the
end so it's a reward for you thank you
by the way
now
the surprise is i don't just have one
bonus tip i actually have five so here
are five quick bonus tips number one
drink a big glass of water first thing
in the morning when you sleep your
metabolism slows down so when you drink
a glass of water as soon as you wake up
it fires up your metabolism at night
time your body repairs itself and it
costs out all kinds of toxins from your
body so when you drink water on an empty
stomach early in the morning it flushes
out those toxins
number two do your workout before you
have breakfast now this might not be
easy for a lot of people i mean it's not
that easy because you're low on energy
but if you want to lose weight and if
you can't do it then do it because if
you work out before breakfast your body
burns a lot more fat number three enjoy
the lifestyle change don't do anything
that you do not like anything that's
going to break you down emotionally so
you go back to your old habits for
example don't do specific workouts that
you hate
if you want to lose weight faster you
need to do workouts right but don't do
workouts that you hate just focus on
things that you love for example some
people don't like running they don't
like jogging so instead choose swimming
or cycling number four just eat green
vegetables and lean veggies that means
cutting out all the carbs that's
something that i personally do sometimes
i just focus on lean meats green veggies
that is good for my body and then the
weight just
just goes but just don't do it for too
long because your body
your body is going to need other kinds
of foods as well number five eat your
food slower studies found that people
who are obese chew their food less than
people with normal weight meaning they
chew just a little bit and then swallow
no take your time chew your food at
least seven eight nine ten times before
you swallow it and then when you do eat
eat smaller portions of food if you
create a habit of eating smaller
portions then you'll take in fewer
calories which of course will result in
faster weight loss think about it this
way if you want to be 80 kilos but you
keep on eating like a guy who is 120
kilos
what do you think is gonna happen yeah
you're gonna stay at 120 kilos
now if you're serious about losing
weight then you need to identify those
bad habits in your lifestyle that is
causing you to gain weight
you can watch that video that will help
you with it right here i'll see you
there and before we go always remember
life is short
so don't waste yours cheers guys